Jenna, here's how this works,
okay?
We have nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box,
take out the object,
describe it to your opponent.
Then they have to guess
if you're lying or telling
the truth.
Jenna, you pick the first box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Three?
[ Drum roll ]
-You are choosing three.
Huh, it looks --
it looks light.
-[ Groans ]
-Yeah, too late.
Too late to act now.
-Now?
-Too late to act now.
I know it's light.
Are you going to lie or are you
going to tell the truth?
Very interesting. Jenna Ortega.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Tapping ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Interesting.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh, I see.
You're making sounds.
You're distracting me. Yeah.
-You don't know what's
happening to you.
-What is in your box?
-Can I be honest with you,
Jimmy?
-Yes, you can always be honest
with me.
-I don't -- I'm -- I'm not sure
I even understand
what's happening here.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't understand
what's happening?
So, this thing that you are now
looking at,
you don't understand.
-I don't.
-Can you describe it?
-I fear of being a bit too
on the nose,
but it is
"Addams Family"-themed.
-Yeah. Well, we knew that you
were coming on.
-Cousin Itt.
Yeah, well, it would make sense.
-It would make sense.
We did book you.
-Cousin Itt.
He happens to be reading
a magazine of some sorts,
perhaps like "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca edition?
[ Laughter ]
-Cousin Itt is reading
a magazine
and it could be "Vanity Fair."
-Yeah, on a nice bench.
-Bench? So, he's outside.
-Yeah, he's outside.
It seems to be a nice park,
Central Park,
if you will, in New York.
-Oh, it's New York.
So he's in Central Park?
-There may be a corgi involved.
-It's a corgi?
-Yeah.
-So, Cousin Itt owns a dog?
[ Laughter ]
Cousin Itt owns a pet?
-I guess so.
-So there's a lot of hair.
There's a lot of hair.
Is Cousin Itt wearing a hat?
-Yes, he is.
Like he always does.
He always has a hat.
-Yeah.
But if you took your time
answering that,
that would mean
that you're lying.
So I think that you are...
telling the truth!
[ Drum roll ]
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Wow!
"Vanity Fair."
-Honestly --
-Chewbacca? It's weird.
That is odd.
-Yeah, I should have lied
because it's way too niche.
Like, the "Vanity Fair"
Chewbacca article, instantly --
-Yeah, we wouldn't do that.
Alright.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
[ Drum roll ]
-Two! Two!
-Oh, my back!
-I already did that.
-[ Groaning ]
Ooh!
-Ohh!
-Ooh! Here we go.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a painting.
-Painting of what?
-Famous, famous,
famous painting.
Something you'd see in a museum.
-I feel like you have to be
more specific on this game.
-I don't think -- I don't want
to be more specific.
I want to be vague.
Think of a famous painting.
-Oh, so it's just a painting.
Don't tell me it's
the Edvard Munch, the --
-"The Scream"?
-Ooh.
-Ooh, that's interesting.
-That's a bit on the nose too.
-Well, you do have a movie
called "Scream" coming out.
So, that's pretty funny,
not niche.
[ Laughter ]
Now, now, here's what makes it
funny.
It's not -- The painting's face.
It's Colonel Sanders.
[ Laughter ]
-Colonel Sanders is very funny.
-Colonel Sanders is funny.
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
In fact, I want to keep it
and hang it in my bedroom
because I love it.
It's so funny. There you go.
It's "The Scream,"
Colonel Sanders scream.
-Honestly, I feel like
Colonel Sanders is pretty funny.
Just to repeat myself.
-He's not supposed to be funny.
He's selling food.
-I think it's -- I think --
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I feel like you might be telling
the truuuuu...
[ Woman shouts indistinctly ]
-Did you just say something
in Spanish?
Wait, what did you just say?
[ Laughter ]
That's not fair.
I feel like you just helped
somehow.
-Maybe it's a lie. Maybe it's a
lie. Maybe it's a lie.
Maybe two on-the-nose
references.
I'm sorry, I'm taking forever.
It's just 'cause
I really don't know.
I don't really care.
I'm going to go with truth.
[ Laughter ]
-No! I was lying!
[ Buzzer ]
The "Mona Lisa."
-Oh, my God. You just took --
-Really a good actor.
Thank you.
-No.
-Did you say my acting skills
are fantastic?
That's so nice of you.
-Yeah, that's ex-- Yes.
-Thank you!
Thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Time to pick a number.
[ Audience shouts numbers ]
One more.
[ Drum roll ]
-I'm serious.
-This is it.
This is it.
For all the marbles.
Jenna Ortega, pick a nombre.
Uno.
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wow, it's a bowling ball.
It's a bowling ball. Wow.
Alright, so it really is heavy.
Oh, my goodness. Alright.
-What if I broke it
or something?
-Yeah.
-Okay. Sorry.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
♪♪
-Why are you being --
Why are you being so serious?
♪♪
Roots, your music is, like,
giving me trips or something.
I'm tripping out.
I'm like, "Wah, wah."
-Uh, we have, um...
It's a bobblehead.
[ Laughter ]
-What is it?
-It's a bobblehead.
-It's a bobblehead?
-A bobblehead of Peter Pan.
Um, he seems to be in a bit more
of a --
like a -- like a business
attire.
[ Laughter ]
He's got kind of
like the Leonard Cohen --
-Peter Pan in, like,
a business suit?
-Peter Pan in a business-esque
suit.
He's wearing a hat that's a bit
more of like
a Leonard Cohen fedora hat.
And he's --
[ Laughter ]
-Leonard Cohen. That's so funny.
-But it's also in a cowboy hat
with wheels
and marshmallows all in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you just naming words?
Are you just saying words?
-There are so many marshmallows
in there.
-You just said 20 words.
-There's so many marshmallows
in there.
-Peter Pan is on a marshmallow?
-No, there's -- So, cowboy hat.
-Uh-huh.
-Truck wheels.
-Yeah.
-Bunch of marshmallows in there.
In there is a bobblehead
figurine of
Peter Pan wearing
a business suit.
[ Laughter ]
-If you're lying,
it's pretty good.
You have a good imagination.
If you're telling the truth,
props to my props department.
[ Laughter ]
Props to props.
Welcome back to
"Props to Props."
-Yeah.
-Jenna, I feel like
we're besties.
And if we are, I would know
if you're lying
or telling the truth.
And I think you are...
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
...telling ze truth!
-I lie.
-Oh, my God!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Come on!
Which one?
-Four!
-Four.
-He was so passionate
about four.
-Yeah, he was very passionate
-Alright.
[ Audience shouting ]
-This could be a hint
right here.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Yeah.
It looked like
it was a little light.
-No, I've just got huge guns.
[ Laughter ]
Huge guns.
-Huge guns. Alright, bud.
-Okay.
-Yep. [ Clears throat ]
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Alright.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-The music. Alright. Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Um, this almost looks like
a children's play set kind of.
You know? Something that
a child would play with.
And it's the Demogorgon
from the show,
a toy Demogorgon, painting E.T.
-A children's play set.
-Yep.
Yep.
-What does that mean again?
-I don't know.
It's up for interpretation.
-Children's play set.
-And It's painting E.T.
with my eyeshadow palette
from Florence by Mills.
-Ah! Now, I know --
I love Florence.
-Yes.
-I know your makeup line, yes.
-And, um,
that's what he's doing.
With a makeup brush.
-E.T. Yep. Uh-huh.
E.T.. And you've seen
the movie "E.T."
-Um, I don't know. Have I?
-You're very young.
-Am I?
[ Laughter ]
-No, I actually know
how old you are.
Yes, you are young.
But you've seen "E.T." before.
You loved it?
-Loved it.
-Yeah.
What character did you love
in "E.T."?
-E.T. himself.
-Yeah, I know, but there's
other characters in there.
How about the boy?
-I loved the boy.
-Yeah. What was his name?
-Elliott.
-Hmm.
You do know "E.T."
-Or do I?
Did I just read a synopsis
before I came out here?
-So you have a child's play set,
is what threw me.
That makes no sense to me,
'cause a child's play set --
-Well, do you
have children, Jimmy?
-Yes.
They don't have play sets.
-They don't have toys?
-They don't have toys.
-They're not real.
-Toys are banned from the house.
Toys are banned from the house.
Only books.
A child play set to me seems
like a swing set or something.
That's a play set.
-No. I mean like a toy almost.
You know, something
that you go, "Oy, oy!"
You know?
-Yeah, a toy and a painting
of a Demogorgon, E.T.
Too many details.
I'm going to say,
Millie Bobby Brown, you lie!
-Owwww.
-Oh, my gosh!
Are you kidding me?
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Come on. You're good.
You know how to act.
Come on.
What am I talking about?
Why mess with the best?
I'm sorry.
Of course you're going to be
a good actor.
Which one, guys?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I'm going to put --
My "E.T." for later.
I'm going to put it this way.
-[ Grunts ]
-I'm here with you.
-Okay. Alright. Here we go.
Phew.
Mm-hmm.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
-Uh-huh.
-Oh, my goodness.
-[ Mocking laughter ]
Go! Tell me!
-It is --
It's, like, a child's play set.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It is a bowl.
Full of Chef Boyardee.
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know how to
describe it. Pasta.
-Okay.
-Yeah, it's a bowl of Chef --
I should have said that.
But it's Chef Boyardee,
'cause the can is next to it.
It's a canned food in America.
-Oh, okay. I'm from England.
-Sorry. You're from England.
Yes.
-Yeah.
-Yes, and in that bowl
is a head that looks to me
like Elon Musk.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk head
in the Chef Boyardee.
So it's like pasta
with Elon Musk's head.
-Okay.
-Heads.
-Heads?
-Yes.
It's, like, floating.
-Multiple different heads?
-Floating like --
-How many?
-Four.
I know you are lying.
-How?
-'Cause you're a horrible liar.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
Are you sure?
-I'm positive. I don't want
to ask any more questions.
I know that you're lying.
-No, no, no, ask me --
-No, I -- Okay, fine.
Fine, fine!
I'll ask you one more question.
What shape pasta is it, Jimmy?
-I was lying!
You won! You knew!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's spaghetti and meatballs.
Baseballs.
I thought maybe
you could smell the pasta,
so then I started trying
to make something up.
And I messed up.
-You got nervous.
You got really nervous.
-I did, right?
-As soon -- You know what --
Just for future reference.
It's when --
I just want to make you --
As soon as I asked
how many heads,
you just went straight for four.
-Oh.
-When you just should have
taken one more look
at how many Elon Musk heads
were in that bowl.
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I could really count four.
-Well, anyways.
-But I knew four.
-It's my turn now.
-Yes, it's your turn. Yes.
[ Audience shouting ]
Someone's saying eight.
Five is the one. Okay.
[ Thud ]
-Did that scare you?
-Yeah, it did a little bit.
It woke me up.
Okay, here we go.
-Alright!
-Okay, 'cause the first one
was not a lie.
So I figure, well,
maybe this one
you're gonna probably
think of something.
Or the pressure's on.
Your face is getting red.
So you're probably thinking --
-It's just my blush.
[ Giggles ]
♪♪
Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-It is...
-Uh-huh.
-...a Croc, sandal kind of shoe.
-I know what a Croc is.
-I don't know.
You didn't know what a
children's play set was, so...
-Yeah, I'm sorry. Thank you.
-Stuffed with pasta.
Spaghetti pasta.
Cooked.
And it's going through
the holes of the Croc.
-Mm-hmm. Huh.
-And there's
a watermelon-flavored
Sour Patch Kid in --
drowning, really,
in the spaghetti.
-Now, how would you know
it's watermelon-flavored?
-Because they're green
on the bottom.
And they're one of my favorites,
actually.
I eat them on set quite --
-How do you see the bottom
if he's drowning in the --
-No, I see it.
I can see it from the top.
From the top angle,
I see it's green.
-Okay.
-And also spaghetti
is quite, you know, thin,
so I can see
through the spaghetti.
-Oh, I know spaghetti, 'cause
I was just lying about it.
-I know. I know.
-Yeah.
So you're saying
two spaghettis?
That's -- What are the odds
of choosing two spaghettis?
-I don't know. Ask your writers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Oh, you're good.
Oh, you're good.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
I'm gonna say...
you're telling the truth!
♪♪
[ Sad tuba plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh! You're so good!
You're so good!
Wait. Can I try? One more?
-One more.
-Yeah, here we go.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Three, Jimmy!
-That's my man three
right there.
Yeah, look.
So light. Oh, my gosh.
It's like there's nothing in it.
-[ Laughs ]
-But there might be.
Who knows?
-You're so red.
-Oh, my goodness.
It's just awesome.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
You ready to get
into this world?
-I don't know. Am I?
-I mean my brain.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
See what I saw?
Do you want to see?
Maybe I'll take my time
a little bit on this one.
-Alright. [ Laughs ]
-Is my acting getting better?
-No.
-It's a, uh -- baseball hat.
-Mm.
-But one that holds the drinks.
♪♪
And one drink -- You know those
people that have beers --
-No. I've never been
to a baseball game.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Is it where they drink
the beer through straws?
-Yes!
One -- Instead of beer, though,
one is Pepto Bismol.
And one is...
[ Laughter ]
One is...
Hmm. What is that?
[ Laughter ]
I learn from the best, bud.
One is, uh, hot sauce.
-What kind?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I'm not wearing my glasses,
of course,
but I can tell by the bottle
that it's Sriracha.
-Oh. Sriracha mayo
or just regular Sriracha?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Regular Sriracha.
-Uh-huh.
This is what I'm going to say.
I'm gonna say it is
a partial lie.
I think you are telling
the truth in some places,
but I think that
I've got you on this hat.
I don't think
it's this kind of hat.
You've accepted my suggestion
far too quickly.
I don't believe that
it's one of those beer hats.
-Yeah. How could it be?
-I don't know.
You tell me!
-That's the game.
So you have to make the choice.
-You lie!
-You think I lie?
Oh, I tell the truth.
-No!
-Yes!
Redeemed myself!
I redeemed myself!
Millie Bobby Brown, everybody!
Why don't you choose
the first box?
Any one. Any number you'd like.
-Okay.
-[ Humming ]
Oh, number one. Okay.
-Big shock.
-Yeah, yeah.
Oh, look at this.
Not that heavy,
so that's the first hint.
All right. Here we go. Yeah.
-[ Gasps ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, my God.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Where do I put it?
-You can put it
here in the front.
I won't see it.
Are you going to lie to me...
or are you going to tell
the truth, Taylor Swift?
-I don't have to lie because
I'm very excited to tell you
that it is
a "Wizards of Waverly Place" DVD
with a weird ribbon around it
that says, "I see corn."
-So specific.
It sounds like something
our writers would do,
but then you're delivering it
very innocent.
Which makes me think that
you're maybe...making it up.
Now you're laughing that I said
you're making it up.
-I could be doing
a double bluff.
-All right.
I'm just going to say it.
Taylor Swift, you are...
telling the truth.
-I lied!
-[ Buzzer ]
-Aah!
Come on!
Oh, my God.
-I lied.
-You lied.
You did it.
-I lied.
-Oh, my God.
-I have a binoculars set
with corn stuffed in it.
It's very upsetting.
It has baby corn at the top.
It's bad.
-I'm sorry.
-You should have known
I was lying
because I will do anything
to bring up Selena Gomez.
Anything!
-I want to --
It's my turn to pick.
Which number shall I pick?
[ Audience shouting ]
Here we go.
[ Grunting ]
-Ah. Okay. This is excellent.
This is really rough.
What's happening over here?
Okay.
-[ Panting ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Where -- Where do I begin?
Uh...
-It's a good one.
-Yeah.
-It's a family of pinecones
playing "Trouble."
-The game?
-No. The song.
-It'd be relevant.
-"I Knew You Were Trouble."
It would be relevant for "Red."
-It would be relevant.
-That's what I'm feeling.
-I just didn't know if they had
the sheet music for it
or something.
-Whatever it is, it's odd.
It's weird and it's real.
Or am I lying?
-Um, well, maybe you're telling
the truth about the pinecone...
-♪ Trouble, trouble, trouble ♪
-Okay.
[ Drum roll ]
You tell the truth.
-[ Buzzer ]
-I got you!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
-Ahh!
[ Giggling ] Whoo! Whoo!
That felt good.
Man, I'm exhausted.
-That was amazing.
You should be.
-I don't act.
I don't know how to act.
-No, you do.
-Don't know how to act.
-Either that, or we're, like,
the worst poker players,
the worst -- We should never --
We shouldn't be allowed outside.
-We really shouldn't
be allowed outside.
-Too gullible.
-We're too gullible.
-Yeah.
-But you know what?
But here we go.
This is the last one.
This is for all the marbles
right here.
-Yeah.
-Taylor, you're up. Here we go.
Come on. Which one?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Three? All right.
I'm not looking.
Not looking. Not looking.
Not hearing. Not listening.
We can still make noise.
So I don't cheat.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know what's happening.
-Okay.
♪♪
I've got in my vision...
um, a book.
[ Laughter ]
A b-- A book called, um,
"I'm Not Loving It: My Life
Under the Golden Arches,"
and it looks like it's
a biography written by, um...
-Ray Kroc?
-...by a fuzzy monster
with, um, seal hands.
Um, it says
it's written by Grimace.
Is that -- Is that -- Is that
a spokesperson for something?
-It's very famous.
Grimace is very --
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're very young, Taylor.
But, yes, Grimace is giant.
We don't know really
what Grimace was.
Is he purple where you are?
-It's actually
a black-and-white cover.
It's a very serious book.
Um, inside the book, it's --
You know how you can cut out
the pages of a book?
-Sure. I know that.
-Yeah, there's French fries
and a hamburger in here.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Taylor Swift...
[ Drum roll ]
You tell the truth.
-I do.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh! Taylor Swift!
That was stressful. Oh, my gosh.